for years now one of the false claims
that the right has been throwing at the
left in the United States is that the
left wants to defund the police now
we've covered this so extensively
certainly you can go on Twitter or
Reddit and find some people who say
defund the police or all cops or
bastards or whatever slogan they come up
with but overwhelmingly no one wants to
defund the police even those in the
Democratic party the vast majority say
we need to reform the police I've put
out a pretty extensive eight to ten
point plan on how to improve policing
and this includes training and
retraining of different kinds this
includes demilitarization this includes
yes having a an unarmed force that can
respond to certain types of calls but in
some cases it actually might involve
funding the police more in order to get
police away a from the low-hanging fruit
policing that actually causes the
problems anyway the point is you know as
well as I do I'm sure
that defund the police exists almost
nowhere and has no influence on the
mainstream Democratic Party
and suddenly Republican Congressman Jim
Jordan says he's going to defund the
police because Trump was indicted now
he's talking of course of federal police
and it's become very popular for
Republicans to go after federal police
let's take a look at this clip this is
from the Maria Bartiromo program over
the weekend take a listen legislation
write laws and pass legislation so we'll
look at that and maybe most importantly
Maria is we control the power of the
purse and that's we're going to have to
look at the Appropriations process and
limit funds going to some of these
agencies particularly the ones who are
engaged in the most egregious Behavior
so the doj and the FBI
yeah and what I'd really like frankly
yeah the doj and the FBI they want to
defund federal police they say we are
for Law and Order and against defunding
the police but all of a sudden Donald
Trump has to comply with the law and the
legal orders as they love to obsess with
of law enforcement and prosecutors and
so on and so forth and all of a sudden
they say get rid of the entire
department defund the FBI defund the doj
these are the very same people who while
saying we support the police and you're
bad for wanting to defund the police
we're on the side of the rioters rather
than the police when it came to the
January 6th riotus Insurrection and in
this particular case with Trump and we
still listen it's going to be a while
until we know the full scope of what the
repercussions are are going to be we
don't know if Trump will be indicted in
Georgia we don't know if the Mar-A-Lago
search warrant is going to lead to an
indictment the this first arrest and
indictment may only be the tip of the
iceberg for lack of a better term
we don't know but all of a sudden we
have someone being potentially held
accountable overwhelmingly for things
that are on tapes of different kinds I
mean Trump called Georgia and said I
need 11 000 votes give me a break
it's we have a recording and there may
be crimes there and all of a sudden they
don't want accountability they claim to
be the party of personal responsibility
and yet they want to blame everyone
other than the alleged criminal himself
for what is taking place and at its core
one of the aspects of this that we have
to consider is they really seemed not to
believe they might lose back in 2020.
when in summer of 2020 Trump started
with the Biden has no crowds at his
rallies and he's in the basement and
whatever else all of that stuff when all
of that was going on back in 2020 and
Trump started with that they're going to
try to take it they're going to take
this they're going to steal that the
other thing they never thought they
might just lose they didn't really have
a plan for what to do if they lost other
than to lie and claim they won and that
devolved into so many other things
that's separate from the Stormy Daniels
indictment that we're dealing with today
and so their principles mean nothing and
they are the ones I mean listen have
National Democrats called for a
defunding of law enforcement the way
that Jim Jordan does in this video if
they have I certainly haven't seen any
of those examples so they are hypocrites
hypocrisy knows no bounds Republicans
don't care about hypocrisy anymore but
we still have to deal with it on our end
now that they want to do away with the
very law enforcement agencies that are
trying they may not succeed but at least
they're trying to hold Trump in some of
his cronies accountable